quoique ce nom bienvenue à une perle à
la fois je me présente michel robert et
de la nation innu et de la nation
québécoise
certains récits autochtone nous raconte
que nous étions des étoiles avant de
choisir non par donc j'aurais choisi et
20 ans une femme remarquable une femme
incroyable moi maman et gilles audette
de la nation québécoise et comme je dis
à chaque fois le plus beau québécois est
un grand homme
merci à mes parents mais je n'ai pas
souvenir que mon portage de vie serait
parsemé d'événements une expérience
difficile je n'ai pas souvenir non plus
que dans ce même reportage
il y aurait des aventures et des
rencontres incroyables inoubliables
comme celle de l' enquête nationale sur
les femmes et les filles autochtones
assassinées et disparues
l'amf adha c'est quelque chose que je
vais garder en moi pour toujours
c'est quelque chose qui me dit à chaque
jour que j'ai le devoir et la
responsabilité d'honorer les appels à la
justice qu'elles nous ont proposé comme
femme et famille autochtone
saviez vous que ça a pris plus de 50 ans
de représentations et de démarches de la
part des familles pour obtenir une
enquête
si cette enquête nationale est survenu
en 2016
ce n'est pas parce que les peuples
autochtones ont tardé à prendre la
parole
c'est plutôt parce que le canada lui a
tardé à prêter l'oreille
près de 2000 380 personnes ont pris part
à l'enesad à elles ont raconté leur
histoire leur vérité est aussi elles
nous ont proposé des recommandations
d'entendre tous ces traumatismes
intergénérationnel et multi
générationnel qui nous disent encore
aujourd'hui que les préjugés et le
racisme 1m encore les politiques
coloniales
ces politiques ont traversé le temps et
infiltrer les institutions publiques
si bien que climat social qui
désavantage les femmes autochtones
ses cris partout
au canada au québec et dans nos
communautés
comment peut-on changer les choses que
nous pour qu'on peut ignorer comment
peut-on changer les choses s'il ne
sommes même pas au courant
alors pour moi la façon de faire et les
simples et les petites ou grandes adp
recommandent de la voix séparent des
actions telles que l'éducation c'est par
nos relations de construire dépend ou de
maintenir les paons qu'on a déjà en
place
d'informer de rester informés de
sensibiliser de ne pas avoir peur aux
débats alors ce pour moi c'est important
c'est aussi ce que j'aime avec nemo
cassen poser en principal à la
réconciliation et à l'éducation
autochtone à l'université laval
et vous comment allez-vous faire lorsque
nous allons célébrer le deuxième
anniversaire du dépôt du rapport de
l'amf à da soit le 3 juin prochain
quels seront vos petites pas ou grands
pas pour honorer la vérité des femmes et
des filles au docteur je vous invite à
vous joindre à moi pour découvrir une
perle à la fois femmes et filles
autochtones
comment elles nous ont proposé un beau
projet de société
je suis convaincu comme vous et moi nous
aspirons à une société inclusive
sécuritaire et sécurisant une société
qui s'élève nos diversités et nos
différences il ya mai